Guess who benefits from dormat
Christianity? Usually anyone and
everyone who hates and despises
Christianity. If you hate Christianity,
wouldn't you love the kind of
Christianity that believes that it
begins and ends with accommodating you,
being your doormat, never confronting
you, and never judging you, and just
laying on the floor so you can wipe your
feet on it. If I was the ultimate enemy
of if I was Satan himself, that would be
the kind of Christianity I'd want.
wouldn't you? So, keep that in mind as
we discuss, you know, why is this
happening and who is profiting from it,
okay? If you want to destroy
Christianity, let's put it this way. If
you're the enemy of Christianity, and
okay, let's go with Satan. He's the
chief demigod, if you will, in charge of
and hating on and seeking to annihilate
Christianity and Christians. How's he
going to do that? Well, historically he
did it literally through violence,
persecution, death. Okay. What happened
in the early centuries of Christianity?
Well, Christ himself of course killed
his apostles killed the Romans uh start
persecuting Christianity for centuries,
killing and destroying and burning
Christians and throwing them in the
coliseum to be eaten and baldled by
animals. Pretty gruesome and horrific
stuff. Why? because well I'm an enemy of
Christianity. I'm Satan. This is what
I'm going to do. I'm going to destroy
them and their teaching and make them
all go straight to hell my abode. Okay.
Now that is obviously the uh preferred
method of confronting and destroying and
degrading Christianity. Makes sense,
right? Anything actually any forget
about Christianity. Anything that is an
enemy to you and you're willing to
engage in that sort of behavior because
you're not a Christian and you don't
love, you are going to try to completely
physically annihilate and destroy.
That's history. Look at if you watch
history or you have an idea, all sorts
of peoples, I always talk about Muslims,
but it was all sorts of peoples who
completely annihilated and destroyed
their enemies and enslaved them and
engaged in things that will boggle your
mind when it comes to atrocities. But
let's say you can't kill Christians.
Now, what do you do? And well that's the
historical conundrum after Christianity
spread persecution began physical
attacks on Christians and they were
killed and slaughtered and again as I
mentioned at first it was the Romans but
then before long Christian even Rome
itself converted and became Christian
and it seemed like that was the end of
it until a new force arose which had a
diabolical animus towards Christianity
and that is Islam and engaged engaged in
a level of persecution of Christians
which if not as qualitatively as bad
because what Romans did was pretty bad
in the few centuries that Christians
were persecuted. I mean from uh what
Nero kind of starts what around 70 AD
and then by 300 at 300 under Dialesian
it's very very bad then Constant
Constantine comes later and it basically
goes away until Justinian the apostate
comes but I don't think he really
persecuted Christians in that sense okay
but now Islam for 14 centuries has sort
of taken over what Rome was doing to
Christians and not just Islam it's
happening honestly everywhere now Okay,
communist China, communist nations in
general. If you look at sources, uh
India, I know a lot of Indians uh will
reject this, but based on the open
sources I keep seeing, there appears to
be a rise of persecution of Christians
in India and some is pretty horrific
actually. Okay. So it seems to me if uh
there is a diabolical animous and um
mind behind the war on Christianity, the
first and most simple thing you will do
is attack and kill Christians. Okay. But
now what if you can't do that? Yeah. Now
we come back a little into history. So
what happened is first Rome attacked and
then Islam came and Islam swallowed up
threearters of Christendom. Again, I
have talked about this a lot, but it
conquered all of North Africa and the
Middle East and all those nations were
actually part of Christendom. Actually,
the more important part of Christendom,
though most people understand this
today. But what happened then is Europe
became the final bastion, the final
guardian of Christianity. It was the the
final area and it to continue to be
attacked by Muslims for century after
century. If you want documentation, you
can check out any of my books. Probably
Sword and Scimitar will give you the
best overview. So this goes on until
fight and Europe, what does it do? Did
it lay down? Did it become a doormat?
Well, no. Because if it did, that would
have been the end of Christianity. Think
about it. Europe was the final
torchbearer of the faith because
everyone else, like I said, in the
Middle East and North Africa um had been
subjugated, many of them killed, and the
the rest living as secondass dimmies.
Okay? And the only free Christians were
in Europe where they fought savagely
tooth and nail. And that's my other
book, Defenders of the West. And you can
see what Christians had to go through.
They were pious, but they didn't, you
know, they didn't subscribe to Dormat
Christianity actually. And that goes on
and finally actually these Christians in
Europe prevail. They're the strong ones.
And now Islam is on the way. Islam's on
the retreat. And I'm talking about now
we're in the, you know, 19th and 20th
century of the so-called colonial era.
Christianity won. Okay, I'm Satan. I
tried I tried to do what we always do
which is to kill them and annihilate
them and I was largely successful uh in
the Middle East and North Africa during
the Roman times. But these Europeans
maintained and still lived on as
Christians and they fought back. So now
how do I kill them? Ah well if you can't
do it physically you have to do it
mentally, psychologically. And so began
the long subversion of Christianity,
right? And that's what we're talking
about. If you can't engage in physical
persecution, well then you can resort to
spiritual subversion. Okay? And that's
the case. That's what happened now to
the west. They could not be killed. They
fought back savagely for centuries and
they resisted. So there has been now a
concerted effort. Step two, which is to
subvert the faith and have you kill
yourself. Genius, isn't it? And if we
can't kill them, well, let's get them to
kill themselves. And hence where we are
today where Europe is engaged in suicide
because the faith and the underpinnings
of it have been so exploited and
distorted and stripped out of context
that now everything is about oh uh oh I
love migrants. Oh I I don't judge. Oh I
lay down and let everyone come in and
walk all over me because I'm being a
good Christian or I'm being a good
western person. Both of them are
distorted and both of them come from the
same root. Actually this is the slow
subversion that has begun and neared
completion. The the project is almost
near completion of destroying
Christianity and destroying the west
itself which was the domain of
christendom. Okay. And it's uh if we
can't persecute you. So if you look
today around the world there in areas
that are not the west Christians are
being horrifically persecuted. They're
being killed and slaughtered especially
in the Islamic world. But as I pointed
out elsewhere too, communist countries,
India, even in Latin America, which is
nominally Catholic, Christians are
actually being persecuted. So whenever
and wherever Christians can be attacked
and killed, that's what's happening. But
because the West was the final most
powerful bastion of Christianity where
the faith was preserved and defended for
centuries, um you can't go and kill it.
Okay. So we're so now you do you subvert
the minds of those Christians themselves
and have them kill themselves. And
that's exactly what's going on. And the
chief way of doing this in my opinion
has been by transforming Christianity
into dormat Christianity which is
basically engaging in this sort of um
heresy which completely distorts and
undermines which strips love and
tolerance and mercy of the balance which
is uh yeah we love you sinner but we in
no way shape or form are going to allow
this sin to exist. Okay, that has now
been stripped and so there's nothing to
defend and Christians have just
completely lost all form of vigilance
and uh they are they are the chief
vehicle of this of the destruction of
themselves. Okay, pretty diabolical and
nifty way of thinking for Satan, huh?
Think about it. Honestly, this is this
is what I see as a person who's been
studying history. Whenever and wherever
Christians can be physically killed and
assaulted, they are in in in the case of
the west and Europe which is rather
singular because that was the final
bastion and that is where Christians
fought so hard and uh you if you've seen
my books defenders of the west the two
swords of Christ sword and scimitar it's
a constant war and these guys were very
militant okay which is the exact
opposite of dormat Christianity okay and
which is what was necessary to actually
keep it alive I'm asking you to look at
the way doormat Christianity is and ask
yourself who profits by this. You're
going to find it's the people who hate
Christianity the most. Atheists for
example uh the most proflegate and you
know sexually depraved people love this
kind of Christianity. They promote it.
Wherever you see you know dormat
Christianity being sponsored and
supported. Yeah. You know what's going
on. There's a reason because this is the
kind of Christianity that's meant to
weaken you and make you basically uh
subscribe in your own destruction,
thinking you're a good guy and patting
yourself on the back the whole time like
a fool. All right? So, little wonder
that this kind of Christianity is pretty
popular. You if you go to a big church,
the famous churches, the ones that get
all the money, that's what they're
teaching. Of course, because they're
being heavily funded by people who hate
Christianity,
and they want you to think this is what
it's all about, for you to lay down and
be a doormat so they can do their thing
and get along uh with their agenda
without having you get in the way with
getting getting in the way with uh in
the way of them. But bring back the
fight.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.